and the world thought the two can't sit
together sit together we we we uh we
love each
other we love each other truly lived in
total Harmony and peace for for
literally for hundreds of
years so we were taken in um by the
Muslims and we lived there and
flourished they had the Muslim and then
the Christian Muslim was the largest and
the Christian was the second and then
you had the Jewish community live
together in the same Courtyards Babys
sat each other's children in fact
I I was just I in facted me with this
key because everybody family the mus
people from Palestine they carry around
the key Muslims basically gave the Jews
their lives back they they they were
able to to exist to go to flourish and
have
pal Illinois six-year-old boy was killed
and his mother was critically injured
when they were stabbed by a man who
targeted them because they were Muslim
islamophobia is gaining ground and with
your support we can push back asalam
Alum brothers and sisters this is your
brother Eddie from the dean show and
islamophobia is real and it's hurting
our community innocent lives are gone
and most people are unfamiliar with
Islam's true teachings this guy right
here this guy's trying to build a DA
Center in our country I'm not talking to
you right now you're a c you're trying
to build a DA center with the grace of
God Almighty Allah the Creator and You
by our side we can help change that at
the dean Center we are spreading and
Sharing The Message of Islam submission
to the crater not the creation combating
islamophobia building community and
expanding our media reach don't just
watch from the sidelines be a part of
the change click the link below donate
right now may God Almighty Allah reward
all of you we are making history today I
have two
individuals here in the dean show Studio
we have an orthod othodox Rabbi and we
have a she
Imam without further Ado let's get into
this exciting episode dispelling many of
the myths that are out there showing the
people the truth with my next two
guests I love you you're when I was
ready to talk about I would only talk to
I was explaining how much respect I have
for the faith of Islam show Welcome to
the de show the de
show Rabbi Weiss the legend how are you
alhamdulillah thank
God and Dr Imam dalii how are you
alhamdulillah they say a picture is a
thousand words but now video is going to
be much more so we have a a organic
gazin Palestinian it's correct yes and
then we also have an Orthodox Jewish
rabbi and the world thought the two
can't sit together sit together we we we
uh we love each
other we love each other J before he yes
see the main right now someone's tuning
in and they've been watching Fox News
and they're watching all the other Hanes
and all the other uh mainstream pugnet
they're like you know uh it's a Muslim
Jewish thing but they're watching now
they're getting a totally different
story
yeah with the help of the May first I
pray to the almighty to bestow upon me
his truth his wisdom that I may be
worthy of conveying his message and so
sanctify his name and inshallah bring
peace to the world well you're saying
it's this is so much the nakba this this
colossal uh this catastrophe it has so
many facets but of course the slaughter
and as um our distinguished Imam was
going to talk I mean we can't there's no
words now to talk this sometimes uh we
say in one of the vers of the Torah that
sometimes silence is what because
there's no words to describe what is
happening in Raza um and the IM
personally
has it's it's it's beyond words over 30
relatives were just murdered in Gaza I
mean there's no words to describe this
but um but this is part of this we I
call it like a linkx in a long chain of
this har nakba but um but the the the uh
it's predicated it's Zion is on the
narrative that it's like you were saying
a religious conflict when everybody
who's from the Arab Muslim Community or
from the Jewish Community will will talk
about how we lived in total Harmony and
peace for for literally for hundreds of
years we lived and not only we lived for
hundreds of years in peace but uh we
were saved by the Muslim Community wow
that's so we're like REM making history
that's history and we're making history
here today so you have the same thing
here you have uh orthod Rabbi this is a
rabbi in the picture is it well it's I
don't know who this person was I just
got picture some a God-fearing Jew from
it's a Jew and a Muslim together and
they're holding hands just like you guys
were wow that's amazing this is a we
live so this is before this is in in
Palestine before 1948 right and and not
only that but we have to remember that
uh throughout our history the Jewish
people um unfortunately Christianity had
an idea that they have to convert um or
else you people took Christianity or
else you're going to burn in hell and
they tried to they made the Inquisition
uh with they they tortured people to
convert out of the religion and so the
Jewish people had to run away many were
murdered but and also they were banned
from the lands from Portugal and Spain
and um and um where did they go it was
the Muslim lands that took in the Jews
throughout this history although we have
a distinctly different religion but we
believe in one God and and and it was
never an impediment to coexistence even
though we have distinctly different and
there was no human rights groups to
protect we simply were embraced given a
safe haven and we flourished we
flourished in their lands we put out our
greatest Torah authorities our greatest
rabbis and for hundreds of years our
communities grew and grew and whether
you go through all all the Arab and
Muslim lands whether it's Iran whether
it's Iraq whether it's uh Egypt
Lebanon Morocco Tunisia turkey wherever
you would in Palestine so we and
Palestine has a special story that when
the there was Jews were thrown out from
Palestine 100 years ago and was the
uman um they to took the Jews back in so
we were taken in um by the Muslims and
we lived there and flourished so they
had three distinctive communities they
had the Muslim and then the Christian
Muslim was the largest and the Christian
was the second and then you had the
Jewish community and with a different
religions but they live together in the
same Courtyards Babys s each other's
children in fact
iys I was just I in fact I recorded it
just yesterday um I I I was at am
conference and a person the Elder
gentleman came over to me and he spoke
about how his father um um that they
when they used to go um uh doing
business or whatever he
the Jewish would neighbor would take
their children and his jewelry to
because he didn't want to leave it alone
and he would take it over to this his
father's house to this Arab Muslims
father's house and they would leave them
there and leave it there with and so
this is a I mean this is I could tell
you so many beautiful anecdotes of um
both the Jews helped the Muslim
neighbors and the Mas the like like it
should be like abely question Humanity
that's how it should be but and and
because because God says that we have to
to do kindness God has we have to
emulate God's compassion and we so these
people live together God-fearing people
live together so that's the basic so
it's really tragic when you know people
today when they see a Muslim and a Jew
greeting each other they say wow it's
like a surprise that is one of the core
uh catastroph part of the catastrophe of
the NAA so over this is historically
documented it's known you're repeating
the history I mean this is known amongst
learned people and unfortunately many
people don't read today and don't study
history but now for over a thousand
years Jews and Muslims live together in
a relative peace certainly and Jews fled
persecution from the Crusades from the
inquisitions to Muslim lands and there
wasn't this this hostility towards Jews
on the contrary it was cont like I say
it was it was uh a case where the
Muslims basically uh gave the Jews their
lives back they they they were able to
to exist to to go to flourish and have
communities and so it's like that's part
of the tragedy like it it's it's and we
have with God's help we have to talk
about why what I mean what why does
Zionism uh insist on uh portraying like
there's a religious conflict What's
Happening Here what's their issue what's
their goal we could talk about that yeah
sh what do you think uh we know this
history but it's different when it's
coming from a a rabbi you know an
orthodox Rabbi who's talking about this
and uh we're seeing what the media is
pushing they're creating this division
between they're trying to make it like
it's a Muslim Jewish thing and what are
your thoughts I really appreciate you
the truth nothing but the truth and
honestly when we went together yesterday
you see and a yahoodi
not Jewish not Zionist different between
Jewish many Rabbi by the way many Jewish
friends from Iowa from Texas they call
me about what going on in Gaza right now
against completely what going on by the
way 1948 I born 61 in
Gaza my father have a we live in Village
called fuja now in Hebrew hebon heon now
fuja
fuja my I have a house I have a k by the
way and the did until now we have
this when I was in high school I told my
father I want to see my house I said no
they will kill you because they killed
many of your uncles my father ran away
from
fuja 1948 to Gaza to
Gaza
sorry then I went there with the key I I
knocked the door because my second
language is Hebrew actually and he says
this is my house and he said it's not
your house I have the key I said yeah we
took everything key and the deed the
deed from the Turkish okay the of the
house doesn't matter you want to see the
house soon and he met me inside the
house but he the way he humiliation used
to be but not yours you have the deed I
have another deed another Deed from whom
from the government we never sell our
houses and I found out actually in fuja
in fuja a way actually 10 minutes from
jerusalema many houses many
houses they know but also they are
completely hated for by the way for the
Jewish themselves they hate Jewish say
belong belong to us this area belong to
us then we migr to Gaza my father my
grandfather Gaza I born
1961 since I born
in
1967 exactly I was s years I went to
first year in elementary school they
completely attacking Gaza my father my
brother H Hassan got killed over there
and destroyed my school in that time was
alive hundreds of kids and families die
in that time 1967 hundreds you you
mentioned a word now many some people
might not
be educated on this word Zionist so
making a distinction between the two you
can help us understand so you have so
the the the issues here between not Jews
and Muslims but
Zionist who you would say have hijacked
Judaism is that correct yes yes um can
you help uh the Layman who never heard
this term zionis and is it true also
that this Zionism was created this is
what's ironic by Theodore herzo and the
like who are actually atheists right
this we'll try with God's help to be
concise and bring but first I carry
around with me oh this key this key was
given to me I went to bajaja refugee
camp in Lebanon and they presented me
with this key because everybody family
the musl people from festine they carry
around the key to show that they they
they they didn't give up their hope that
they're going to be returning to their
home and have back their homes so I
carry that key with me wow yeah um and
um yes so let's try with God's help but
just very concisely to explain
Zionism uh let's start the other way
with God's help Judaism is a religion of
3,000 years of ago Moses went on Mount
Si the Jewish people God took the Jewish
people out of Egypt Egypt and they made
a covenant with god um on Mount Si and
God gave them the Torah to the laws to
follow the Commandments of the Torah 613
Commandments and we uh we have to be
subservient to God that's we made this
Covenant that we will be subservient to
God and how do we serve him by following
the laws of the Torah um and and this is
we strictly adhere to the laws we're not
allowed to change it because it's from
God it's not that we can pick and choose
um Zionism the they is a
transformation to nationalism it started
around 140 years ago 150 in these this
time a group of people got together
totally arranged from the religion they
were not religious people these were
people who detested the religion and
they and they decided that they want to
create a nationalism a national home
with all the strappings of a national
home an army uh Olympic team and all
these things and that's what they were
considering their Judaism andat Judaism
a transformation to nationalism now in
every way you look at this Zionism it's
uh contradictory to what Judaism is
first of all we again our issue is to be
subservient to God to keep the spiritual
the laws of the Torah while they are
just using the facade they're making a
creation a nationalist material concept
of having a piece of land a piece of
Real Estate and with the strappings of
like every countryes have all the issues
but nothing to do with God in fact they
declare today that they're a democracy
oh you you don't practice do practice do
whatever it's and yet they have the
audacity to call it Judaism a religion
but that and then they add to that that
when they say we need a home one of the
excuses they say we need a a home
because uh who's going to protect us we
have to have guns we need an insurance
policy they called so they so we say to
what who's going to protect us we are we
are Jewish we believe in God this is how
there's a God we pray to him every day
we look to him for for protection H
where was God they say you know just
they spew blasphemy where was God they
ridicule us where was God throughout
history to protect so the it's predicate
the whole Zionism is rooted in blasphemy
and and saying that you know they laugh
and Scorn at the people who look to God
for protection no you need you need to
take a gun if not you're a fool you're a
backward thinking so so that's the root
of Zionism blasphemy and then the fact
that um they they're creating a state
God foresaw that there will be people
who will not uh believe in him respect
him um look to the almighty for our
sustenance of life and and to live so
when we were get taken out of Egypt by
God by the almighty through Miracles
given take we were taken into the Holy
Land the walls of Jericho sunk in it was
everybody saw the Miracles was done in
front of all the million people whoever
were there but then God stipulated that
we have to be on a very high level of
Holiness of Purity if not the land will
reject us like a body rejects a foreign
object it's very sensitive the land so
we will eventually 2,000 years ago
that's a thousand years from after we
took the Torah we were rejected we were
sent into Exile all the prophets this is
not like my idea Jeremiah Ezekiel Isaiah
anybody who just reads the prophecies
and you'll see that the Torah warns that
if we're not going to be on that proper
level we will be sent into Exile and the
prophets this in the Bible itself it
says in the five books of Moses and the
prophets warned the Jews that it that's
coming and that happened with the
destruction of the temple 2,000 years
ago we were then once we were dispersed
amongst the Nations not because of our
physical uh lacking that we were didn't
have a strong Army clearly we say it
every Jew says in his
prayers because of our sins because we
were not on that level so we know it's
because of our sins and God's brought
this about yes it happened to the Romans
the Greeks but it's Bas it's because of
our sins and then we were put on The
Oath by God that we are forbidden to re
attempt to return and mass in large
numbers make a Jewish State even if it
would be not like the state of Israel
even it would be a religious concept of
serving God we would still stand
entirely in opposition to this concept
because God put us in Exile and Only God
Only The Almighty can take us out and he
will do that one day we believe but make
a miracle where all Humanity will
believe in God and everybody together
will go up and serve God that's the
Jewish belief that all Humanity one day
will stopping atheists they all come
together and serve the almighty there'll
be a metaphysical change in the world
but till that day comes we are told by
God have patience God is compassionate
he sees what we're suffering do not
attempt to leave this Exile do not make
a Jewish sovereignty even one inch one
cimeter of Jewish is forbidden and
that's why for 2,000 years we went
through the Inquisition Cru ades there
were times in history in 2,000 years
when there were Jewish communities that
were roing of I thought I call it I'm so
sorry I did CL it before I don't know
what happened sorry I apologize so we
had that that there were times it was
called Golden Age of Judaism and um and
and and and yet they never and there was
letter us to the my manes rambam out
great leaders they and they told people
asked maybe we should try to make a land
no they were told it's forbidden and and
so we'd never attempt to make our own
sovereignty Zionism is a movement that
just relative recently and they totally
ignore all the 2,000 years that we were
in Exile and that we we suffered and yet
we didn't make a state they're going to
come along and they're going to make a
state because they want to because
they're nationalist nothing no respect
for the rabbis no respect for the Jewish
relig on top of that if they would make
a state in an empty land which they
wanted to make in Uganda and Patagonia
they were going to buy because it's
practical it's lost they wanted a
productive land it was before the time
of uh technology that was going to but
so when they started Zionism like 100
years ago but then they had a meeting in
1890s in Bassel Switzerland they decided
no you need to a lot of backing a lot of
support for a state so they're going to
go to Palestine and they're going to
make the state there they're going to
make the state in Palestine so um the
world will say oh the will say wow
children of Israel are going back to the
land of is it's a it's a terrific
opportunity they're going to use the
Bible but you're going to ask them what
are you with the Bible you're not
religious you don't want that you were
not but but they don't have morals
because they don't have the morals of
God that you know this they're cunning
people they're fooling people they're
using somebody's else somebody else's
identity what does it bother them
because they're ready to sacrifice on
the alter of Zionism the people of Gaza
the Jewish people and anything that
stands in the way to reach their goal so
the creation of a state is expressly
forbidden for Jews in an empty land even
in an empty land but being that they
decided to go to Palestine Palestine the
inhabitants were the largest community
were Muslims then they were the
Christians and the Jews let's just leave
the Jewish issu on the side the Jewish
Community but they're creating a state
by basically usurping it by taking it
from the Muslims and oppressing them
killing them what we see 75 years of of
of of death and suffering so this is a
double Rebellion again it's it's it's
rooted in blasphemy it's Crea state is a
breed
uh of the laws of the Torah that warns
us not to try to attempt to leave Exile
and on top of that they're doing it by
killing and stealing so that's totally
antithetical to Judaism it's
contradictory to Judaism and all the
rabbis we put out a book called The
rabbis speak out it's a compilation
what's it called the rabbis speak out
130e record of religious Jewish
opposition to Zionism and this you can
see from the rabbis from around the
world every country we're not talking
there's tens of thousands of rabbis but
these were the major uh the codifies of
and everything I always I turn to this
page the because everybody in all the
world uses his books he codified he
condensed the laws because laws are
massive and he put it into a he
condensed it it's called Mish brur and
so everybody follows his teachings and
he says um I quote him the zionists are
dead limbs of our people which causes
the entire body to rot and that's just
one example of the many leading rabbis
what they with their opinions about
zionis and he was he passed away 1933
what was his name he was called Rabbi is
Mayor hohen Cohen means uh from the
Priestly tribe and he was he was uh P he
passed away 1933 so before 1948 was St
but the Zionism was flourishing already
then so the rabbis saw plenty before the
state yeah and I'm going to just add I
know I'm being a little thing one more
issue if it would just be like I say
that the they're rebelling against God
and the and they're stealing and killing
they're doing everything that's against
God is but on top of all of that is the
fact that we are required by God to show
gratitude for good that is done to us
it's part of the Torah we are taught to
show gratitude Moses didn't Smite the by
the time uh uh plagues he gave he didn't
Smite the water that it should be turned
to blood he gave Aaron to do it because
he said the water protected when he was
a baby they put him in a wicker basket
and to and and he was hidden there so
because Pharaoh was slaughtering the
children and he was in the so he said
how can I smite the water that's what we
teach our children you have to show
gratitude even for water even for every
so here uh here how dare they theist in
orderorder uh uh uh to to try to
solidify to create their state they have
to make a narrative because there are
people there who who are fighting back
who are standing up and saying what are
you doing you're stealing my so they
said oh they tell the world they're
anti-semites they hate the Jews they're
evil people and they and they
successfully for 75 years years built on
that and built on that till we have
today in Gaza that people are watching
for 50 days almost now it's 50 days
everybody sees it live minute after
minute another person another person
50,000 2,000 3,000 be withholding by
16th the world and the world is because
it because they dehumanized the people
of Palestine with the Zionist narrative
that they're evil when on when truth
these are the the the people who took us
in who gave us a home who gave us life
how dare they to to vilify people who
saved their parents and grandparents so
the rabbis stood up around the world and
and and and stood up and for not only in
in Palestine the chief Rabbi of
Palestine now when I say the chief Rabbi
Palestine I don't mean uh the Zionist
Rabin it they use the Star of David they
name the Israel they make a Rabin it a
chief Rabbi all to make it look
legitimate
kosher and and that they could tell the
world that they're spiritual they're
Godly and if you stand something's wrong
here let me I'll throw you the phone I
don't know why I keep on closing it I
don't know what it's doing I think it's
a eye in
his I'll throw if you can
take something with it give it to I
don't know what
happened um here so you see the chief
Rabbi 1920s of the religious Jewish
Community what was his name this Rabbi
zeld he's the chief Rabbi I heard he
sent Messenger to Britain saying that I
think I think you told me this last time
we spoke I spoke to a rabbi Shapiro
another Rabbi you know Rabbi Shapiro
there's Yakov Shapiro maybe he's a very
special person yes he's a very nice uh
man he I think he was telling me that
they sent a this Chief Rabbi he sent a
messenger to the British to say look we
don't want this right we're good and
then they assassinated this this
messenger oh I'll tell you who that was
his name was um Dr is yob danan his his
blood should be Avenged this is we put
out this AA of the true religious Jewish
opposition um I'm sorry the true
religious Jewish position on Al AA and
here um so one of the statements is and
it's he sent I'll just quote it here
um it is critical to note that Rabbi ysf
Kim zeld of blessed memory the anti
Zionist Chief Rabbi of the Orthodox
Jewish community of Palestine which was
from um he Liv he passed away in 1932
before the state from 1844 1848 to 1932
so already in 1929 he issued a statement
in Arabic in a local leading Arabic
newspaper called El Salam and he
clarifying and stating the unambiguous
Jewish position in regard to Al AA and
the Temple Mount he said un quoting the
Jews do not want in any way to take that
which isn't theirs and they certainly
don't want to contest the right of other
inhabitants to the places held by them
which they regard with honor and
consider holy in particular there is no
Foundation to the rumor that the Jews
want to acquire the Temple mount on the
contrary from the time that because of
our sins we were exiled from our land
our whole our Holy Temple was destroyed
and we have been lacking the Purity
required by the Torah it is forbidden
for any Jewish person to set foot upon
the grounds of the Temple Mount until
the coming of the righteous Messiah who
with the spirit of the almighty will
rule righteously for the good of all
creation and return to us the Purity
required by the Torah this is the Jewish
view like I say the Muslims by the way
so they you you would think maybe they
feel threatened because we believe that
they'll come a messiah and no because
they know we say when the almighty will
make the the coming at the end of time
we believe a certain way they Muslims
believe a certain way when when the end
of time will come we you know we certain
there be this way Muslim say so that's
not a problem because we're not taking
any action because we're forbidden to
make any to try to preempt this so the
Zionist with their creation of the state
and every facet everything they're doing
the the they uh they're they're
rebelling against God with the creation
estate fully and the rabbis like I said
the the rabbi here um um Rabbi zeld
bless memory went and with and met with
the king of trans Jordan and and wrote
Arab newspapers this was the 1920s and
said we do not want we want to be loyal
citizens we don't we don't and then when
he passed on CU it's a lifetime the next
chief Rabbi was rabbi shinski of bless
memory and Rabbi daninsky was in the
time of 1947 19 where they wanted to
create ratify the state so he spoke to
the United Nations and this is United
Nations documents we went with a
delegation he said we furthermore wish
to express our definite opposition to a
Jewish state in any part of Palestine
this was the view of the Jewish
community that was living there for
hundreds of years and um and then he
passed on then we took up another Chief
Rabbi you can see the tens of thousands
of Jews when we took up the next chief
rabbi um and and these are the
communities that are living there
they're thriving there they still the
anti-zionist thousands of Orthodox Jews
protest BB Netanyahu is BB Netanyahu is
he also an atheist you know secular I
mean I he's a rebel against God whether
he wants to claim he believes in God I'm
not going to go into because it's vile
to to to to um to uh how would you say
to uh uh to play around in in in in
excrement I'm sorry so I don't I'm not
going to go into what he is what he
isn't um what he says he believes or he
doesn't but one thing we know he's he's
a rebel against God he's the the uh he
is the head of the den of Thieves he's
the head of what you would call the
mafia it's like the this Zionist state
of Israel that he's the head whether he
would have a long beard and roll his
eyes and talk about God all day doesn't
nothing it's it's he's leading the
Rebellion against God the murder the
mass murder of people but I'm saying
even if you wouldn't do a mass murder
but the the the the occupation is every
second that it exists is a rebellion
against God we're not allowed to kill
we're not allowed to steal we're not
allowed to occupy and and it's rooted
like I say that that God doesn't protect
us and he said that but just a few
months ago he said you know that people
have to come to Israel again because
that's that that's but and and here this
is in the United States this in front of
the White House when he came to Natan
came to Vis the President Obama then so
we we always have all these different I
just have uh I just try to bring certain
pictures of times but we do this every
year we go out and demonstrate and when
he came to visit the president when all
through the age when they come to the
Prime Minister Israeli Prime Minister
comes we go out and demonstrate tens of
thousands and say they have you know
like it says um uh Israel has no right
uh to rule over any part of the Holy
Land B natano and the state of Israel
does not represent world jeury and I
just see we this we do not only here we
do that in pales in London in in in
Canada we demonstrate and there what
happens is when you demonstrate they get
viciously beaten they get uh children
old children you can see children by
it's not only police it's the Army old
men and they assassinated you were
mentioning Dr danan Dr danan was um a
diplomat who lived in Denmark and he was
very he was very friendly with the king
of Denmark and he decided to become
religious he was brilliant man a poet
then there's a monument for him in
Denmark so he went to the uh um the king
king of Denmark escorted him he decided
to become R he was going to become a
Zionist he's going to go to Palestine
that's what he thought he went there and
he was a serious person he was looking
for the truth and he right away became
aware that the Jewish Community the
religious community is anti-zionist so
he went and he started he was a a
brilliant Diplomat he he started he
started protecting the Jews Britain this
was be 1924 22 24 in that time Britain
required of the Jews when they had the
Mandate that they should register under
the zionists imagine that they come in
these interops the zionists came and the
and so he went and he fought them and he
was able to extract that the Jews don't
have to register that then he said I'm
going to go to Parliament and I'm going
to make them aware that the whole issue
of this so-called Jewish uh movement to
have control over the it's not the
Jewish populace it's not the Jewish uh
community of hundreds of years there so
the Zionist warned them that was the
today that's that's today the IDF this
terrorist
organization that's they call Israeli
Defense Force you know all psychological
I that was so they warned him they're
going to kill him and they assassinated
him cold blooded in front of sh sedic
Hospital in the streets of J and here I
just showing you that the the
ongoing is this sh is this something
that's common knowledge between in the
amongst the mus the Palestinians Muslims
and Christians there who live that they
know this differentiation this is these
are the zionists who are doing this and
they know the difference between the
Orthodox who are against this uh before
I say that something very important I
believe millions of people going to
watch this this show is number one and
I'm talking about the people in America
United States of America please brother
and sister Muslims Christian and Jews
and Ed all kind of religion we have
to I appreciate with the rabbi to listen
to Rabbi he saying the truth nothing but
the truth
islamically islamically same thing even
you quot it
from Moses this is in the Quran also
many stories in the Quran and the mother
of the
Moses the the key we know that we know
when I grow up actually unfortunately I
grew up with the occupation I grew up
with occupation since I grew up killing
and killing and killing continuous
killing my family of course my brother
from my eyes he got killed got my point
I say
islamically we are he agree with
everything he says he's agree 100%
number two us as American now us I
believe a lot of Jewish believe the
truth but to get a position like uh
Biden Trump and Congress and Senator and
APAC especially the APAC they're
controlling our government
100% does Islam you're an expert in the
Quran and the Hadith does it teach
Muslims does the Theology of Islam teach
to hate people who are Jewish absolutely
not when when when any kind of fight any
fight see do not kill a person a c
civilian do not kill especially a Woman
No Woman No Child not even a roed tree a
tree do not do that only whoever fight
you and Allah said that
inak what's the verse chapter 68 verse
in the Quran where Allah God Almighty is
saying Allah does not forbid you from
showing kindness and dealing justly with
those who have not fought you because
your religion or driven you out of your
homes
there's no no Force anybody for the
religion Allah know what the truth agree
but he is saying actually that real M
give me attention a real now
in Palestine they change the every
day not the one I learned when I grow up
I learned the Quran the because I'm a
Palestinian we have second language is
Hebrew and we are underation we speak
the language so I read the the in the
beginning when I grow up almost the same
thing you now when I went back I was
reading completely different sorry the
majority is different different many
many things many things different now my
point whoever in CU land Je over there
actually not Jewish
Zionism know they are not believing in
not believing in in in in what Allah
sent them to Moses MOS Moses peace be
upon him can we compare uh it has me
thinking when uh Moses peace be upon him
when he went up to get the uh Ten
Commandments and then you had people who
ended up going astray and worshiping the
calf is it the same story in the Torah
that you have I I you you said it very
concisely so so can we equate these are
similar same people who deviated at that
time people who are deviating at this
time can we make can we make a can we
make a contrast there are there are um
yeah it's it happens to be that some
great rabbis the chief Rabbi of
Palestine title B
bless um used to say that sometimes like
it goes into the soul of a person um the
sinners like they come in reincarnation
and stuff so you said there are the
people well who who did that um uh
reincarnated like doing evil and they do
it again um that evil so it's possible
but you know we don't they know these
things but both are evil yeah when we
talk about Orthodox rabbis how is it if
someone now who's living in that
environment and they're following can
you tell us about certain rabbis who are
very popular there uh such as Yousef
of have yes how where do they stand the
people like yeah so you see you know
just because somebody could be very
knowledgeable yeah a scholar you know
who I'm talking about yes yes he's not
alive anymore yeah and then he has his
son also now who's taken so somebody
could be uh a a computer in his mind he
could be brilliant but that doesn't mean
he's
God-fearing we had it happens to be that
that ofad Yos was a student of
anti-zionists great holy rabbis he was
yes and unfortunately
just Zionism in order to give themselves
uh that legitimacy that aura of
legitimacy of Holiness so they paid for
rabbis they had and and that and so you
always find amongst uh tens of thousands
of R you can always find somebody who's
their soul sold their soul and so he was
unfortunately sold his soul and and and
was unfortunately was the front the face
of Zionism because he was very knowledge
at the same time he did he he stood as
the uh the the weapon of the Zionism
because he's using the Torah to uh
justify to uh to legitimize to to to
give the stamp of approval the state of
Israel it's and our rabbis mind you at
at the same time that he was Chief Rabbi
and so forth of the state of Israel we
had a Rabin it we had great rabbis who
were God-fearing and um we still but I'm
saying you know and and and we had no we
didn't look at them with we wouldn't
take them into a quum we wouldn't use
them to pray with them we wouldn't pray
with them we wouldn't go in the same
room as them we consider these people
sinners sinners and even worse I mean
they the the evil to the core because
they're rebelling against God and every
concept what there is to rebel against
God that God can't protect us and so
what I say it's it's rooted in pure
blasphemy you know that our children not
only that but like they support the
Israeli Army that the people people
should go to the Israeli Army these
Chief rabbis and so forth our children
that are living there the hundreds of
thousands of Jews that that and their
anti-zionist they refuse to go and
there's a mandatory military service so
what do they do they um they they refuse
to go and they get they become criminals
imagine every boy and girl who turns 17
becomes a criminal from our community
because they refuse to Ser he said girls
not only boys and the IM the immorality
that's going a girl into an army with
with people who are non religious you
can imagine what's happening there so
they don't refuse to go and but that's
we refuse to go because we don't want to
stand and support um and be part of the
state of Israel you know there a
rebellion against God so they go and
they get arrested they this is part of
their psychological warfare they put on
them the Israeli they force on them to
wear instead of prison guard the Israeli
Army guard you see a girl here she's
crying she's saying Psalms she's praying
to God because they're arrested every
single boy and girl they can't travel
it's such problems you have no idea how
the Jews are being oppressed there I
mean like you know there's so many
pictures thousands of these pictures of
the brutality that it's used against the
Jews and um here they're spraying them
with uh stink water that destroys their
clothing and it discourages people to go
to demonstrate because they're poor it
ruins their clothing and they they their
body smell from stink water it's it's a
chemical that they use because that that
way they know they they don't have more
clothing so they and but it doesn't help
we still go out and demonstrate there
would be tens of thousands more who be
out in the streets not only there but in
the United States when we demonstrate we
get threats are we this two weeks weeks
ago no it's already maybe four we when
one of the demonstrations I went out I
came back the tires were slashed from
the car and the mirror broken and
the and this is nothing that's nothing
to what the threats death threats and so
forth but here thank God God this police
that and so and so we're protected um
but but but in other places in Israel
the police are are the ones that
perpetrate the crimes not only the
police they have the army that come out
in the streets as you see and and
brutally beat and and assassinate the
people like Dr danan I mean the history
is a long history maybe the first famous
martyr was this Dr danan Who was a Jew
why why do you think now because you're
seeing this is anti-Semitism this is
attack directly on real Jews real Torah
following so why don't we see the
mainstream media here because they're
talking about anti-Semitism is growing
because of what's going on but have you
had the media come to you and to share
these stories um well um do the media
come to listen to us it's um to talk
about the zionists who are doing the
anti-Semitism well we talk about it it's
I mean I was you you you were showing me
a clip I had many times that I was
attacked while we were demonstrating
that there was full of press there I
don't see it happened in France we went
to in France we were I mean I could go
you don't see that people make an issue
of it I have a colleague he's an older
that goes against the narrative yeah and
he's in he's 80s he's he's lived 120 a
Dean he was a dean of a school he's a a
distinguished Rabbi he speaks up against
Zionism his car tires was slashed tens
of times they shot into his house and
the police so far never never
um this is where in New York no in
Manchester England I'm just saying so
people you see when people see this what
that what zionists do to the ones who
are speaking up against them that they
know what they're doing that we never
accuse the Zionist of of of being uh
slouches or you know they know what
they're doing when they have this what
they accomplish is people are afraid to
speak up unfortunately or else there
would be like I say tens of thousands of
more Jews speaking up if it wouldn't be
for this intimidation the attacks but
the chief Rabbi of Palestine Rabbi tidle
Bam um moved out when he was in 60s and
70s chief Rabbi he moved to New York and
he urged his followers he
said if you can move away move out
because you're giving support
unknowingly even by being there so tens
of thousands moved away not and we have
all around the world we have schools
that are followers of it's called satar
and uh so he urged people he said go out
demonstrate so be he said at the cost of
your life you have to tell the world
it's not Judaism it's not the religion
and and and it's not the people who are
true to the religion who are supporting
who are doing this people think that the
more the religious the Jew the more you
are pro Zionist they have to R it's the
land of Israel it's so ironic it's so
sad that's part of the
because how many tears we cry the people
of Gaza now you have no idea in our
synagogues how many people I but but
this is now I mean crying foran 75 years
I remember I mean old the rabbis who
were some few good few of them aren't
alive anymore they remember there sin
they remember what and when they would
talk about it they would grit their
teeth they would talk about how how how
the designist they're doing to this
crime against such good lovely beautiful
people our neighbors and and and people
who are so good to us and and and so
what could we do so we pray to God and
we go out and we demonstrate then you
was mention you're literally you're
literally like these are Rabbi crying
for the Palestinians 100% this is we we
we have they they accuse now like I was
saying how could they perpetrate a crime
now just this last link in this NBA this
Gaza the murder of so many people that
every SE minute by minute people are
watching and you know the time doesn't
allow us you know talk about in
individual that we should be spending
days about each individual life and and
how they un and how they died I mean
it's just tragic and then somehow lying
and excruciating pain they don't have
medication and then they don't have uh
food water and and and and under the rub
I mean I don't this is a a conversation
for it's just it's beyond words like we
just last night we were crying we were
hearing a t some some some a few people
at would describing what happened to the
relatives over there so I mean there
what and yet the zionists were are doing
this because like I said they
dehumanized to to the world the people
of Palestine and they were successful in
doing that and they declare
anti-Semitism and that is the way
they're able to occupy because they say
not they've taking that they came a
bunch of Interlopers and took the land
no they have a narrative that was an
empty land more or less and there was
just a few people there who hated Jews
you know cuz nobody had at that time
internet and so there was a few media
outlets and they had control of it so
they kept on saying you're hearing some
problems over there oh it's just a few
anti-semites you know continuation of
the Nazis or something they're
anti-semites and they hate so they were
able to to solidify that narrative make
that narrative stick for so many years
till they were able to come to this
level what's happening in Gaza now I you
said anti-Semitism yes they let's think
what anti-Semitism anti-Semitism means
that you create a hate against Jews
because they're Jews who is the greatest
uh creator of exacerbating anti-Semitism
not I say they the anti-Semitism was
before then Jews were killed by Hitler
my grandparents died in aitz the
majority of my my father escaped from
the Nazis when they came to Hungary but
and almost allil but who was the ones
who are exacerbating anti-Semitism today
in the last 75 years in the greatest
form that you don't even have Jewish
communities in a lot of the Arab lands
they disappeared when we were flourished
for hundreds of years there nothing
existing or maybe a little Remnant who
did that there was one thing that
changed not the religion we lived
together for hundreds of years there was
no human rights one thing changed the
introduction of a of an ideology called
called Zionism the the um uh the
implementation of the state of Israel on
the the foot on on the on the on the
neck of the Palestinian people that is
what changed nobody it's logical it's
it's just simply base um logic that God
gives a person to understand the only
thing that transpired is the change is
the creation of the state of Israel and
since not since the creation of the
state before them when they started
making Zionism which 1920s 1910s since
then there's endless rivers of Bloodshed
so who wait the Palestinian people and
the Jewish people who they
cold-bloodedly beat and murder and even
their own zionists there's a river of
blood that's because they want to
implement their thing so people be who F
get conned by them fooled by them join
them whatever May reason it may be
maliciously or not but they're dying so
tens of thousands of Jews also die
through the history now all because of
was so who is an anti-semite tell me who
is anti-Semitic they are the
personification of anti-Semitism they
are the ones who should be labeled as a
um a case um example of what
anti-Semitism is is the state of Israel
what they're doing in Gaza we the world
dare not be silent we cannot be silent
besides everything that we're talking
about what they're doing to Jews what
they're doing to to that they destroyed
the Jewish communities and all the Arab
what the what the Palestinians that
they're living in refugee camps in
squalor and and don't have a life for
three four generations or maybe five
already but now every day in Gaza it's
it's to show the world the world has to
see that to think back be introspective
and say what happened to me what
happened to the world that they could be
silent when they're seeing the that
because they say they keep announcing PR
with with a force that because there's
some terroristas we're not going to get
into what that all that they excuse use
but so I'm asking you if you take a a a
man who's a murderer runs into a
schoolyard with there's a thousand
children there which country which
governing body will say that you're
allowed to throw a bomb on the thousand
children because you want to kill some I
mean it's the defies they're insulting
common uh sense of the of humanity in
what they're doing and that they're
being supported we dare not be supported
I don't know what we can do first we
have to pray to God the go body is
compassionate that because we don't
understand when he brings a plague it's
we don't understand why this but we we
have to pray to him he should stop it
and we have to we must not be silent we
dare not be silent I can't bring back
your relatives we cry with there's no
words but we what we have to do for the
people that are still alive we cannot be
silent and because we're Jews we must
speak up and we do speak up not as as
much we can I'm not blaming people
because of the attacks they're getting
but we must speak up and we try to and
we plead with the world we plead with
our President we plead with the
political figures of you would make um
you would something want to dwell into
something about Islam you would respect
the Islamic leaders if you want to speak
about Christianity you can respect the
pope and them if they have something to
say about it how come the Jewish people
who have these beautiful the largest
concentration of religious Jews uh
God-fearing is in Williamsburg Brooklyn
there's not one Israeli flag there in
Jerusalem
these are the communities that following
the religion that didn't divert from the
religion they give their lives to the
they they they pay for schooling they
private schooling each child causes
fortunes and caus fortunes and they have
large families and they pay they're poor
they have they uh they pay for their
clothing for the co of food how and when
it comes to Israel they all against
Israel what are they crazy if it's such
an important thing to for why but
they're against it there's not Israeli
Flags not there in May there's
Palestinian Flags there by the way the
same thing is in Stanford Hills in in in
London where invariably any country with
it's a very religious they're anti- the
state so how come our president why
doesn't he respect why doesn't he turn
to the Jews say look we having problems
there people are dying so and you pe you
Jewish people who are the distinguished
Scholars say that the problem is because
they they're going away from the words
of God we live together and we can't
live together we want to live together
as they pleaded with the United Nations
why can't we do that we can live
together peace we have lived together in
peace we want to live together in peace
and it could be done history attest to
it the only impediment to Peaceful
coexistence is the the uh implementation
of this FL selfish state of
Israel ideology called Zionism wow uh
your thoughts before we conclude Dr Dali
honestly last year I was with my family
my nieces and I was planning actually
when I go over there to teach my nieces
my nephews swimming and those my
nieces are my nephew they already got
killed and all of them actually won't
believe it no I really appreciate what
you just said
because
sorry situation now my my sister and my
brother my my cousin actually were work
in the hospital and they text me many
many picture and videos
we're not allowed to be in the social
media not in the Facebook get stop it
the massacres literally massacres you
know I have a picture actually I cannot
show it actually I don't know because
they're going to stop my social media
Facebook and Twitter and this going to
stop it completely if I share this
picture even de they going to shut Dean
show also if I show the picture but the
massacr by the way canot even imagine
you canot imagine this kids the slau of
the kids don't know we don't we don't
know what to say we don't we don't have
words it's it's and it's being done in
our religion and our thing we can we can
only continue to work together yes this
the key we're making history here today
that's the key showing that a Muslim
from Palestine a Palestinian and
Orthodox Jew Muslim can sit together and
like you said it's beautiful we can we
have and we want to live together in
peace we will will God will and yes we
will inshah yes it is he he always we
will inshallah I believe sooner or later
sooner or later we we wake up now sooner
we're going to pray in M AA together it
says in our Torah it says God says why
are you rebelling against me it will not
be successful we are certain our rabis
constantly say this there will be an end
to this occupation we don't know when
we're not prophets we pray to God every
day he should bring it back CU God is
compassionate he can do make anything
happen that he should bring about
speedily and peacefully because he can
make anything happen like the USSR
didn't allow to L us so he can make it
happen he can make it end so we pray to
him at the same time we say do not be
intimidated you're not anti-semitic if
you speak up against you do and
get go speak to anybody who you think
can have some influence which you have a
politician don't be afraid to speak
speak up and do and do and do and
support and send whatever help you can
they're not letting help into God's but
do and do and do as much as it's humanly
possible I think we've shown here I mean
for anybody who's been watching the
mainstream media they're tuning in here
this is we've dispelled this myth you
went into the history you've shown for
over a thousand years there was a
relative peace between Muslims and Jews
living together and Christians there in
Jerusalem there wasn't this kind of
chaos that's going on so that farce this
is a straight out just lie that's being
the narrative like you said they need a
narrative they're pushing this narrative
but we're combating this narrative right
now by making history Allah said that in
the
Quran whom except of the Jews become
real
Jews and Allah knows the best but only
few not the majority of the Jews and
he's right with that and not a lot
beautiful beautiful Rabbi Weiss anything
you want to say in closing yes so again
first of all we speak to the people of
Gaza they should know that uh we are
praying for them constantly around the
world in Palestine my brothers and
sisters and the ones around the world we
are hurting with you we feeling with you
and um and we all know there's a great
God who's compassionate and um we went
through uh Hitler five six years like I
say it's in our blood so we know what it
means suffering I mean I I I could also
tell stories of you know what we went
through that time of the murder and and
atrocities and so forth but we didn't
lose trust in God we don't and we will
not so we pray to God who's
compassionate and God will bring an end
to this suffering and insh he'll bring
an end to the whole occupation which is
in in this case the cause of and then
you will see you'll be surprised to see
so many so many Jews the trth to the
Torah who know the Torah that they that
they'll be hugging and um and and
embracing the palestin say here's he
land back but not only that there will
be many many Jews who are misled by
Zionism what the Satan we say always
fools people but when this is going to
pass you're going to see that the people
are going to are going to be uh totally
bro broken by what they did and they're
going to look for ways to repent on this
we hope that that it will happen many
people today are changing their views
from the Jewish even ReliOn because that
they see they see what is total wrong
but we're saying God will bring it and
and this is to the people of Gaza I
believe that they should hear and to the
people in the refugee camps but but to
the people around the world the non-jews
please do not use our Religion Don't
callot the Jewish State don't callot
Judaism because when you say Jewish
State when you want to talk about it
they right away the on I'm talking the
ones who are trying to do for the for
the Peace by saying the word Jews or
Jewish State you're playing into the
hands of natano and them because they
want to be able to say oh he's
anti-semitic it's not anyways a Jewish
State it's Zionism it's hard to to say
it because it's looks they call it the
Jewish State all time they the zionists
want that but in Iran for instance
they're very careful that's why they
hate Iran so much the zist because they
they they thei was very careful in
differentiating between Judaism and
Zionism and they have synagogues that
have the Jewish Hebrew letters people go
pray there I went there many times and
this and and and all the leaders Inbal
andas yes yes all these leaders they
they publicly announced that they're not
against Jews and the zionists want them
you to say Jews so then they can accuse
of being as don't say that be careful
and we're pleading with the world
everybody should do what they can and
we're pleading with the Jews use again
common sense how come the very religious
the authorities of Judaism whether it's
brisk whether it's in
Lithuanian how come the very religious
that give the lives for the for the
Torah observant how come they're
anti-zionist if you're looking for the
truth then you step back and realize
you're being fooled by the Zionist
propaganda by the teaching by the facade
of the Chief RAB let us all Embrace God
his Torah and and and and and do what he
wants with the god should help the
removal of the impediment to peace the
Zionist state of Israel then we can live
together in peace in harmony a free pal
we be able to give the Palestinian
people their lives return to them and
ultimately we pray for the day when all
Humanity will recognize one God and
serving him in harmony yeah you you also
you've had so many um organizations
Holocaust Survivor who have also spoken
out and knowing what had happened this
evil event that Muslims condemn Islam
condemns this Holocaust and the slogan
was often never again so now anybody who
has a heart who believes in God this is
their chance to truly never again it's
not never again but now you're excluding
the Palestinians this is never again for
anybody for Jews for for Muslim for
anybody for this to happen but it's
happening in 4k and people are watching
but they have a chance now like you're
saying to speak up to create awareness
and thank you for Eddie for D show
really this the best things for other
the whole world to watch this to see us
that mean that that Rabbi saying the
truth and I'm so so so happy I I really
I appreciate the sitting here yes second
time we third time actually we s
together but now for the didn't show
millions of people going to watch that
God will and maybe soon soon free free
pal
in
pal thank you the de show is an old show
already you knowre it's going to get
white beard like me they doing go good
God's work to spreading the word and
thank you God bless thank you thank you
and thank you guys for tuning in thank
you go ahead and create that awareness
so we can truly be people like the rabbi
was saying that we can he showed the
history yes we did live together in
peace we can live together in peace and
we want to live together in peace don't
be fooled by The
Narrative and do your part so we can
stop this eradication of human beings
babies that are being killed thank you
very much peace be with you assalam
alayum leave without giving you a gift
if you're not yet Muslim and you tuning
in to see what these Muslims are talking
about and you like a free copy of the
Quran go ahead and visit the Deen
show.com we'll take care of the postage
and everything and get it delivered to
you and if you still have some questions
B Islam call US at800
66247 52 we'll see you next time until
then peace be with you assalam alaykum